MALE SPEAKER 1: Welcome to all
you Googlers out there.
And a very warm welcome to Lenny
Ravich, who came all the
way from Israel and is the
author of a great book,
actually, which I read a few
years ago, which is called "A
Funny Thing Happened on the
Way to Enlightenment."
Obviously, he is, in addition to
being a psychologist and a
very impactful speaker,
he's also a humorist.
And we were guaranteed by Avi
that we're going to laugh, and
that we're going to enjoy
ourself, and that we are all
going to leave smiling.
And hopefully, by leaving this
room smiling, we will then
have a positive influence on
everyone else in the office.
And we will all go
home and smile.
And then, we will
have a positive
impact on our families.
LEONARD RAVICH: Play
it forward.
MALE SPEAKER: And, yeah,
we will pay it forward.
So I look forward to laughing
and smiling and feeling a
little bit better.
So Lenny, over to you.
And thank you very much
for coming to Google.
We're very happy to have you.
LEONARD RAVICH: My pleasure.
My pleasure.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD RAVICH: Yes, thank
you very much for coming.
Before I begin, I would like
to ask a question.
How many of you would like to
have a more flourishing life,
a more joyful life, open mind,
feeling good, looking good,
live longer, live stronger?
If there's anybody here
like that, would
you raise your hand?
OK, you almost forgot.
How many people would not like
to have a more flourishing
life, live longer,
live stronger,
look good, feel good?
How many people would not?
OK, I just want to check if
I was in the right place.
Because I'm going to talk to you
about all of those things
and how to achieve them.
I will be giving you some
things, which we call
attitudes, that I've discovered
along my journey.
But first, I'd like to tell you
a little story about how
this all began.
I was working in Tel
Aviv, in Israel, at
the Ministry of Education.
I was an inspector, a supervisor
of teachers.
If anybody doesn't know what an
inspector is, it's a person
that used to be a
teacher and then
decided not to work anymore.
In 1996, I went out
on pension.
And since I've been out on
pension, I've been having
nightmares.
I keep dreaming I go back to
the Ministry of Education.
And I start out on a journey of
my own to find out what is
the one thing that all people
in the world want.
What is the most valuable thing
in our lives, which we
probably don't think
about too much.
So I started sending out
mails, Facebook, I met
strangers on planes and
asked this question.
What's most important thing
for you in your life?
What is the most valuable
thing to you?
And what do you think the most
common answers were?
Let me hear what you think.
What were the most
common answers?
AUDIENCE: Being happy.
LEONARD RAVICH: I'm sorry?
LEONARD RAVICH: Being happy.
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: Tulsi.
LEONARD RAVICH: Susie?
LEONARD RAVICH: Sucie.
AUDIENCE: Tulsi.
Tulsi.
LEONARD RAVICH: Tulsi.
Thank you, Tulsi.
OK, anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Health.
LEONARD RAVICH: Again?
LEONARD RAVICH: Health.
Who said that?
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: [? Clea. ?]
LEONARD RAVICH: [? Pia? ?]
LEONARD RAVICH: [? Clea. ?]
AUDIENCE: [? Clea. ?]
LEONARD RAVICH: It's very
clear, [? Clea. ?]
Being healthy.
OK.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: My family.
LEONARD RAVICH: Again?
LEONARD RAVICH: Family.
Family.
Your name?
AUDIENCE: No.
LEONARD RAVICH: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: I was going
to get you a family.
OK, so we have happy.
We have healthy.
We have family.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Meaningful
relationships.
LEONARD RAVICH: Meaningful
relationship.
And you are?
AUDIENCE: Loren.
LEONARD RAVICH: Loren.
And that's Alex.
OK, I almost got you confused.
OK.
AUDIENCE: That's all right.
LEONARD RAVICH: OK, may
I ask you a question?
Let's say the most important
thing in life to me is family,
and I get to have a
wonderful, strong,
functional, healthy family.
I'd like you to fill in this
one word in a sentence.
If I have all of that,
I will be a [MM]
person?
Happy.
Somebody said health, yes?
If I have health, perfect
health, wake up in the morning
perfect health every day of my
life, I will be a [MM] person.
AUDIENCE: Happy.
LEONARD RAVICH: Happy.
OK, who said happy?
Happy, OK.
What else did we have?
We had meaningful
relationship.
If I have a real meaningful
relationship, a long lasting,
meaningful relationship,
I will be a--
AUDIENCE: It's a
trick question.
LEONARD RAVICH: Trick
question, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Fulfilled.
LEONARD RAVICH: Fulfilled.
And if I am fulfilled,
I will be--
AUDIENCE: --happy.
LEONARD RAVICH: Happy.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: OK, so the one
thing we all want is this
thing called happiness, or joy,
or positive feelings.
Now, of course we want it.
How many people here
are parents?
OK.
How many people here are
children of parents?
If I asked you as a parent, or
any parent in the world, what
do you want most for
your children?
I want them to be--
AUDIENCE: --happy.
LEONARD RAVICH: Happy.
OK, we keep going back
to the same subject.
We all want that.
And I'll tell you why and how
to achieve it in some ways,
the awareness at least.
They asked John Lennon--
anybody remember John Lennon--
AUDIENCE: Yep.
LEONARD RAVICH: When he was in
grammar school, John what do
you want to be when
you grow up?
And his answer was, I
want to be happy.
So the school officials decided
that John Lennon
didn't understand
the question.
Later on, John Lennon said
that the school officials
didn't understand life.
So we all want this thing
called happiness.
And what is it?
It's something we don't
talk about much.
They don't teach you much in
school or at home about what
the word feeling is.
It's a feeling.
It's a positive feeling.
And what does this positive
feeling do for us?
Why do we want it so badly?
Number one, it not only
feels good, but
according to research--
Dr. Bernie Siegel's book "Love,
Medicine and Miracles,"
anybody read it--
OK, he says that, as a
general rule, happy
people don't get sick.
You with me on this?
OK, it protects your health.
Being happy, being in a positive
state of mind, happy
people don't get sick.
That's what he says.
According to Barbara
Fredrickson--
and I recommend that you
read her book, called
"Positivity"--
says people who have this
positive feeling, people who
are feeling this happiness or
this optimism of this hope,
live longer, live stronger.
Remember in the beginning I
asked you, who wants to live
longer and live stronger,
look good.
This is all researched stuff.
This has been done by her and
her researcher in her book.
So we all want this
positive feeling,
because it gives us health.
It gives us long life.
It makes us look good.
It makes us feel good.
It helps us in relationships.
It helps us in our family and
all kinds of relationships.
I would like to give you five
attitudes, because thinking
positively is not
going to do it.
I once saw a movie called
"American Dream" or something
where this woman is in a car and
she's putting on her tape,
these empowering tapes, I'm
a strong woman type thing.
And she's over and over going,
I'm a strong woman.
So all these positive thinkings
doesn't really help.
What really helps is attitude.
And what is an attitude?
It's a way of looking at life.
Because everything you think and
everything you feel has an
effect on the chemistry
in your body, OK?
If you're feeling stressed out,
if you're feeling fear,
if you're feeling anxiety or
anger, your body is producing
a chemical called cortisol.
And cortisol is a poison.
Enough days of cortisol, and you
could end up with a thing
called stress-related
illnesses.
And I don't care what your diet
is and how much you jog.
This will get you.
If you're feeling good, if
you're feeling positive, if
your feeling's this happy
feeling, what happens is your
body produces endorphins.
May I have a drink?
Is it OK?
Thank you.
Endorphins lower stress, protect
your immune system,
and even strengthen your immune
system, making you
strong against colds, against
sicknesses or diseases.
You look much better.
You feel much better.
So here are the five
attitudes.
I'd like to know if you
are willing to take at
least one or two.
Who is willing to commit to
taking one or two of these
attitudes back with you, out
of this room and into your
life, and maybe playing
forward?
Raise your hand.
OK, the rest of you
can get out.
OK, the first attitude is, let's
talk about the worst
thing you can do.
The worst thing you can do is
take yourself seriously, OK?
Seriousness is a disease,
dis ease.
It's not funny.
My father told me when I was a
kid, he said to me, Lenny--
he used to call me Lenny,
because that's my name--
this side is a lot more
intelligent than this side,
I'll tell you that.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: He said,
Lenny, don't
take yourself seriously.
Nobody else does.
I said, thanks, Dad.
Anyway, one of the things
that you can do--
and keep this in mind.
This is an awareness session.
Because only in one hour,
I can't go, boom, you're
changed, but you can
get an awareness--
and that is, at every
opportunity, laugh at yourself
and breathe.
By laughing at yourself, you're
not belittling yourself.
You're not lowering
your self-esteem.
You're doing the opposite.
You're saying to the world,
I'm not perfect.
I made bloopers, mistakes,
defects.
And I have addictions.
I laugh at them.
And I accept myself.
And that's the way it is.
It Is the highest form
of humor that you
can possibly do.
And try to think about this
every single day of your life.
Any time you make a mistake or
you did something wrong,
instead of saying, oh, stupid,
say, hey, this is fun.
Let me give you an example.
When I was a young
man growing up--
I grew up in the
United States--
and I had a dream.
And that dream was I wanted to
be a radio and television
announcer, you know, the guy
that sits in front of the
camera and delivers the news,
like a news [INAUDIBLE],
whatever it is.
And so I went to school in
Boston, to a school called
Emerson College, where
they taught theater.
And one of the subjects I
learned was broadcasting,
where they taught you how to
speak like a radio announcer,
an American radio announcer.
And you had to speak something
like this.
And now, back to our show,
"The Flying Chicken." I
practiced this so much, and I
got into this voice so much, I
couldn't get out.
It was embarrassing.
I would go to a party.
Hello, John, how are you, go
home, hello, darling, how
about a hug?
I finally got a job at
WAPI TV and Radio
in Birmingham, Alabama.
Anybody know where Birmingham,
Alabama is?
It's down south, next to
Georgia, Louisiana, Texas.
And I was very excited.
My first day at work, I sat
in front of the camera.
I had to go on the
air at 8 o'clock.
It is now one minute to 8:00.
The lights come down
in the studio.
And a light goes
up on the door.
It says, on the air.
And then, there's a red
light on the camera.
And the camera comes
in slowly.
And there's this woman who has
earphones, and she goes like
this to me, [POINTING].
And she points to me.
And then the music starts,
you know the music, the
broadcasting music, da, da
da, da, da, da, da, da.
And I looked at the camera.
And I said this.
I said, good evening--
you know, that voice--
and here is the news, read
to you by Leonard Ravich.
Oh, I was delighted.
I had achieved my dream.
I had a dream job, you know.
The next day I came
to the studio.
And I noticed that people's
reactions to me were a little
different, that people
were going like this,
[SNICKERING], like that.
I go, what happened?
I was receiving mail and
telephone calls.
People wanted to speak
to Leonard Garbage.
I said Ravich, they
heard garbage.
I was getting telephone calls.
And people wanted to speak to
Leonard Rubbish, Rabbit.
Is Mr. Rabbit there, you know?
One person even sent mail to
Leonard Ravage, R-A-V-A-G-E,
which means to--
I looked it up-- it means
to rape and pillage.
And I am completely innocent
of all wrongdoing.
So I got an hour
before I go on.
And I'm nervous.
And the cortisol, you know, and
the stress, what do I do?
So I thought, I'll
change my name.
Leonard part, I'll keep
the Leonard part.
That's OK.
But I got to change
the garbage.
OK, so Leonard Ra-- you know,
something with a R-A--
Reynolds, no.
Leonard Roberts, no.
Leonard--
I got it--
Raymond.
OK, that's cool, huh?
Leonard Raymond.
OK, so I went to everybody's
office.
I'm no longer Leonard Ravich.
I'm Leonard Raymond.
Everybody looked up and
said, thank God.
Got in front of the camera,
one minute to 8:00.
Lights come down.
Light goes up on the door,
says on the air.
The television camera
comes in, red light.
And there's this producer who
goes like this to me,
[COUNTING DOWN WITH FINGERS].
And I hear the music,
da,da,da,da,da,da,da,da.
And it happened just
like this.
I looked at the camera and I
said, in that broadcasting
voice, good evening, and here
is the news, read to you by
Leonard [MUMBLING].
I became the first radio and
television announcer in the
history of the United States who
forgot his name during a
live broadcast.
But you had to be spontaneous,
because it's air time.
And it costs a lot of money, so
you have to say something
right away.
So I said, I forgot my name,
but here is the news.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: Washington.
If I'm not mistaken, I can see
you laughing and hear you.
The thing is, are you laughing
at me or are you laughing--
AUDIENCE: With.
LEONARD RAVICH: --with me?
Because when you laugh at
yourself, when you make fun of
yourself, you bring people
closer to you.
It's called intimacy.
My interpretation of intimacy
is in-to-me-see.
And the more of you I show
of me, and I show you my
mistakes, I bring you
closer to me.
And this makes for meaningful
relationships.
So the first tool is laugh
at yourself and breathe.
Now, I want you to take
something back.
I don't want you just to
experience this in your mind.
I want you to experience
it in your body.
So we're going to do something
right now, an experiment.
Now, experiments are scary.
And why are they scary?
Because you leave your
comfort zone.
Because you're going to do
something that you don't know.
So you have two choices.
One is not to take part
in this experiment.
The other is to walk
into the fear.
Because when you are afraid and
do it anyway, you learn
something new about yourself.
So you have a choice.
If you're uncomfortable and
you don't want to do
it, don't do it.
If you're uncomfortable and
you still want to do it,
remember that you're going
to learn something.
Those people who are going to
participate with me, do this.
Raise your finger in the air.
And then you bring it down over
here in front of you.
And you do this,
[POINTING AT SELF].
Now, in about 30 seconds,
you're going to
be laughing at yourself.
You see, you're already
doing it.
OK, so smile.
And when I count to three--
I'm going to say 1, 2, 3-- you
go, ha, ha ha, ha, ha, ha.
OK, 1, 2, 3, and, ha, ha, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
1, 2, 3, and ha,ha, ha,ha, ha,
1, 2, 3, and ha, ha, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
OK, make believe you've got
a flower in your fingers.
Take the flower, put
it under your nose.
Breathe in a very deeply,
and say, aah.
AUDIENCE: [IN UNISON]
Aah.
LEONARD RAVICH: Breathe in
deeply and say, aah.
LEONARD RAVICH WITH
AUDIENCE: Aah.
LEONARD RAVICH: OK, so we're
going to have something now, a
tool, to use when you're in
a stressful situation.
Or if you see somebody in the
office taking themselves too
seriously, you go like this,
[POINTING AT HIMSELF], he, he,
he, he, he, he, he, he,
he, he, he, he.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: OK, how many of
you have driver's license?
OK, how many of you have
been in a traffic jam?
How many people don't
particularly
like the traffic jams?
They can be stressful.
OK, this is what you do
in a traffic jam.
OK, everybody together, even
if you have a car or not.
Put your hand on the wheel, the
steering wheel, that is.
Not that wheel.
This wheel.
And not the other hand,
just one hand.
And you're in a traffic
jam right now.
OK.
And you take your finger
and put it here.
And you say, after me,
I'm in a traffic jam,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
1, 2, 3, and--
LEONARD RAVICH WITH AUDIENCE:
--I am in a traffic jam, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha.
LEONARD RAVICH: 1, 2, 3, and--
LEONARD RAVICH WITH AUDIENCE:
--I am in a traffic jam, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha ha, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
LEONARD RAVICH: 1, 2, 3--
LEONARD RAVICH WITH AUDIENCE:
--I am in a traffic jam, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha.
LEONARD RAVICH: Take
your flower.
Don't take your hand
off the wheel.
Don't look around.
People will be looking at you.
And breathe in very deeply.
Say, aah.
LEONARD RAVICH WITH
AUDIENCE: Aah.
LEONARD RAVICH: One more time.
Take a deep breath.
LEONARD RAVICH WITH
AUDIENCE: Aah.
LEONARD RAVICH: OK, you
can take your hand
off the wheel now.
We're back in the room.
And you have a tool.
Whenever you get stressed-- or
anybody in your house, your
child, your wife, your husband,
your friend--
you can always take
out the flower.
You could always point
your finger,
laugh, and breathe deeply.
Breathing deeply is just as
important as laughing.
Before we go on, I want to ask
you if there's anybody here
who feels any differently than
you did when you first came
in, if there's any difference
in your feeling.
Just check your feelings.
I'm going to explain to
men what feelings are.
Men don't know what
feelings are.
This is the truth.
Men, feelings are things
that go on inside.
OK.
Anybody feeling anything
differently than you did when
you first came in?
Yes?
What What are you feeling?
AUDIENCE: A little lighter.
LEONARD RAVICH: A little
lighter, a little lighter.
And, anybody else?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think I'm more aware
of what I'm feeling.
I'm more aware of the
way I'm thinking.
LEONARD RAVICH: You're more
aware now of what you're
thinking and feeling.
Could you tell me, if you
don't mind, what you're
thinking and feeling?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: On how I can feel
better, on how I can manage
stress or the goof ups better.
LEONARD RAVICH: How you
can feel better?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, or how I can
manage stress, manage goof
ups, manage mistakes better.
LEONARD RAVICH: OK.
And all of that happened
within 10, 15 seconds.
Light feeling?
You get that?
That's what we're talking about,
that positivity, that
thing that makes you feel good,
that thing that protects
your health, the things that
makes you look good and that
makes you stronger, OK?
15 seconds every day, a couple
times a day, and you've got
that light feeling.
You've got that good feeling.
Before I go on, I'd like
a nice feeling, too.
So please give me a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD RAVICH: How many people
here have heard of a
person by the name
of Steve Jobs?
I guess you have.
Bless you.
I suggest that you
go into Google--
Google--
search YouTube.
He's got a speech--
2005--
a commencement speech, Steve
Jobs to the graduating class
of Stanford University.
I want you to listen to that,
because it's very inspiring.
Anybody heard of that
speech before?
Do you remember the last two
sentences of that speech?
LEONARD RAVICH: Stay hungry--
AUDIENCE: --stay foolish.
LEONARD RAVICH: Stay foolish.
Stay hungry, stay foolish.
Now, stay hungry, I guess it
means to be never really
satisfied completely until you
get to your destination,
whatever that is, or satisfy
your passion.
But stay foolish really stunned
me-- and I'll tell you
why-- when I heard it.
Because my parents, my teachers,
all told me,
Leonard, be serious.
You're not going to get anywhere
in this world if
you're not serious.
You're not going to succeed
being a clown.
So I want to do something
right now to have you
experience what it feels like
to do something foolish, and
why did Steve Jobs say that,
and what is that
going to give us?
So I have to look out into the
audience and ask you this.
How many people here, in this
audience, speak a language
other than English, Hebrew,
or Mandarin?
What language do you speak?
AUDIENCE: Portuguese
and Japanese.
LEONARD RAVICH: Portuguese
and--
AUDIENCE: --Japanese.
LEONARD RAVICH: What do
you speak better,
Portuguese or Japanese?
AUDIENCE: Portuguese.
LEONARD RAVICH: OK, but you
can speak Japanese, OK?
And your name, again, is?
AUDIENCE: Daniel.
LEONARD RAVICH: Daniel.
Daniel, would you mind
coming up here?
Have a nice round of applause
for Daniel?
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD RAVICH:
Daniel, stand over here so
you'll be closer to the
microphone.
First of all, thank
you very much.
AUDIENCE: You're welcome.
LEONARD RAVICH: This is a
surprise for you, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: It is, yes.
LEONARD RAVICH: Now, we're
talking about feelings.
So what does it feel like to
stand up in front of your
friends here?
AUDIENCE: I'm used to
it already, yeah.
LEONARD RAVICH: I'm
used to it.
It really surprises me.
Because there was
a research done.
The question was, what is the
scariest thing in the world?
What do you think it is?
They thought the scariest thing
in the world was the
fear of death.
The fear of death
is number two.
The number one fear is--
AUDIENCE: Is that
being on stage?
LEONARD RAVICH: Yes,
speaking in public.
AUDIENCE: With Lenny
next to you.
AUDIENCE: With Lenny.
LEONARD RAVICH: Yeah, right.
Speaking in public is a
fear worse than death.
So the next time you go to a
funeral, just remember, the
guy giving the last speech
over the grave
would rather be--
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: --in
the coffin.
So we're going to give Daniel
a nice round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD RAVICH: Daniel, I want
you to do something for me.
We're going to play a scene.
AUDIENCE: All right.
LEONARD RAVICH: Can you give me,
just explain to me, just a
little bit, a stressful moment
at work, just one little
stressful moment?
AUDIENCE: OK, someone didn't
clean the micro kitchen.
LEONARD RAVICH: Somebody what?
AUDIENCE: Someone
ate their stuff.
And then, they just left it
in the micro kitchen.
LEONARD RAVICH: OK, they
left it in there.
AUDIENCE: And I was
upset, so much.
LEONARD RAVICH: OK,
you're upset.
So I'm the one who did it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LEONARD RAVICH: Now you come
to me, and you are upset.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LEONARD RAVICH: And I want to
talk to me and be upset in
Portuguese.
AUDIENCE: In Portuguese, OK.
LEONARD RAVICH: Now,
why Portuguese?
Because I don't know
Portuguese.
But I'm going to be foolish,
and I'm going to speak
Portuguese gibberish to you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LEONARD RAVICH: But please
don't laugh, OK?
But answer me as if you really
understand me, seriously.
And then, I'll answer you, as
if I really understand you,
like me and my wife, OK?
AUDIENCE: OK.
LEONARD RAVICH: Because what
happens when you get foolish,
you go into the right brain.
And when you go into the
right brain, there is a
thing called empathy.
And you start to understand
each other even without
understanding each other.
Because you go into a place of
understanding that is not logical.
Am I making myself clear?
Well, you'll see in
just a moment, OK?
You come to my office, and
you're really upset.
And this is in Portuguese, OK?
I'm on my computer right now.
Act one, scene one,
take one, action.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[KNOCKING]
LEONARD RAVICH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Lenny,
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE].
LEONARD RAVICH:
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH].
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
LEONARD RAVICH:
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
AUDIENCE: No, no, no, no.
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
LEONARD RAVICH:
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
LEONARD RAVICH: Huh?
AUDIENCE: [PORTUGUESE]
LEONARD RAVICH:
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
LEONARD RAVICH: [GIBBERISH]
LEONARD RAVICH:
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
AUDIENCE: [PORTUGUESE]
LEONARD RAVICH:
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
LEONARD RAVICH:
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
LEONARD RAVICH:
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
LEONARD RAVICH:
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
LEONARD RAVICH:
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: Wonderful.
Thank you very much.
Wait a minute.
Let's give him a round
of applause.
It was great.
I would like you to have
this copy of my book.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LEONARD RAVICH: Come
to me later.
I want to sign it for you--
AUDIENCE: All right.
LEONARD RAVICH: --and give
you a signature.
One thing before you go.
I want you to know something.
How many people here
know Daniel?
Raise your hand.
You don't know Daniel.
There's one thing about
Daniel you don't know.
Daniel was in a great,
cruel race, the
cruelest race in nature.
He was in the great
sperm race.
There were millions of sperm,
all trying to get to that same
egg, but Daniel wouldn't
give up.
Because only the fastest, best
and healthiest and strongest
get to the egg first.
I'm so sorry that so many of
your brothers and sisters died
along the way.
AUDIENCE: Lord knows.
LEONARD RAVICH: Do
you have a car?
AUDIENCE: I don't.
LEONARD RAVICH: Do you have
a motorcycle, bicycle?
AUDIENCE: I have a bicycle.
LEONARD RAVICH: Put this
on your bicycle.
And you'll be foolish.
It says, I won the sperm race.
If you're foolish enough to
put this on your bicycle,
you'll take Steve Jobs
seriously, OK?
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Lenny.
LEONARD RAVICH: Thank
you very much.
OK, nice round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD RAVICH: OK, so what do
we get out of being a little
bit foolish?
I can't leave and come over and
talk to you in gibberish,
because it won't pick me up.
The mic won't pick me up.
So I'm just going to
have to ask you.
We were foolish for a while.
And Daniel, for one thing,
was very creative.
This was a very creative
moment.
It was a moment that we really
connected even though we
didn't understand
the language.
What did you get out
of being foolish?
Why did you think that Steve
Jobs wants us to be foolish?
Anybody feel anything or think
anything or that anything
happened to you while
we were doing this?
What did you get out of it?
AUDIENCE: We laughed.
LEONARD RAVICH: Sorry?
LEONARD RAVICH: OK,
a good laugh.
AUDIENCE: And he didn't
get cornered.
He wanted to be mad at you and
get you in a discussion, but
you just, by dismissing--
LEONARD RAVICH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --that seriousness,
you lost it.
LEONARD RAVICH: OK.
OK, so we got a laugh
lot of it.
Can you think of anything
more important than a
laugh in your life?
It's pretty important.
OK, so now we have
two attitudes.
One is to laugh at yourself
and breathe.
And the other one is
stay hungry, stay--
AUDIENCE: --foolish.
LEONARD RAVICH: Stay foolish.
You do foolish things.
As a matter of fact,
talk gibberish.
Or just do something foolish,
like putting a little sticker
on your car or your bicycle
that says I won the sperm
race, and you've done it.
And you feel better.
And you have a good laugh.
Before I go on, may I have a
round of applause, please?
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD RAVICH: About 11 years
ago, I was sitting in a
restaurant of a hotel that
I was staying at.
And the waitress was
taking my order.
And at the end, she said,
will that be all, sir?
And I said, yes.
And she said, thank
you, and left.
Now, where I come from, I
never heard a waiter or
waitress say to me "thank
you" by taking my order.
Never happened.
So I was curious.
And so when she came
back, I said,
can I ask you a question?
Is it the policy of this hotel
for you to say to a guest
"thank you" for taking
my order?
And she said no, that's what
I got from my home.
We were taught that if I have
a chance to serve someone,
it's an opportunity for me
to get closer to God.
I was stunned.
She said, why did I say
thank you to you?
Because you gave me an
opportunity to get closer to
God by asking me to serve you.
Now, why did this have
me in such a shock?
Because it's the first time in
my life I had ever met a
person who looks at service as
something godly or holy, that
actually helping another person
or serving another
person is a holy act.
But you know what
she did for me--
I thought about it-- and she
did it for you, too.
She gave us what our purpose
and mission in life is.
Our purpose and mission
in life is to serve.
Think about what you
do every day.
It's service, OK?
Our purpose and mission in
life is to improve other
people's lives.
That's the whole reason around
Steve Jobs, Bill Gates.
It's all about improving
people's lives.
That's all they wanted to do.
So our mission and purpose
in life is what?
Its our meaning in life.
Everybody needs a meaning.
Let me just tell you
how important
meaning is in your life.
If anybody's ever read a book
called "Man's Search for
Meaning" by Dr. Frankel, Victor
Frankel, he says that
in order to have meaning in
our lives, it gives us the
reason to live, the reason to
live, to have meaning, OK?
And if your meaning is service,
if your meaning is
helping other people, improving
other people's
lives, that gives you
a meaning in life.
And I want to just tell
you one little story
about having meaning.
And all of you, before you leave
today, I want you to
make that decision.
My meaning in life is, and
finish the sentence.
And I'll tell you
how it's done.
Across the street from my
house, my apartment--
I live in Tel Aviv--
there is a dry cleaning shop.
I bring my clothes there.
And there's an elderly man.
When I say elderly man, I mean
my age, which is like
extremely mature.
And I have a show that
I do in Tel Aviv.
I have a show at the theater.
And I gave them two tickets.
And I said, come to my show
and enjoy yourself.
They came to my show.
And when I brought my clothes in
the next day, they said, we
were at your show.
And the man said to me,
you know, that you are
performing a mitzvah.
If anybody doesn't know what
a mitzvah is, in the Jewish
religion, a mitzvah is
doing God's command.
It's a command from God.
He said, you're doing a mitzvah,
because you're making
people laugh, and you're
teaching them how to be happy.
This is a mitzvah.
And he said to me,
you know what?
I am also performing
a mitzvah.
I clean your clothes so that you
could go on stage and do
your mitzvah.
Did you see that man did,
that I want you to do?
In that one second, split
second, instead of saying,
I've got to clean
these clothes.
I've got to wash these.
Look at all this laundry here.
My god, what am I going to do?
That's what I do.
All day long, I do this.
What meaning does
my life have?
He gave himself that meaning,
that moment.
I clean your clothes so that
you can go on stage clean.
And you do your mitzvah,
and I do mine by
cleaning your clothes.
Were both doing God's command.
So please, before you leave here
today, make up your mind
what your meaning in life is.
My mission and purpose,
and I think it's
yours, too, is service.
It's improving other people's
lives any way you can.
That's the way to happiness.
That's the way to feel good.
That's the way to positivity.
And before I go on, I'd like
a nice round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD RAVICH: OK, I think
we're doing OK.
When I was younger, my father
told me, Lenny, live every day
as if it's your last,
because one day
you're going to be right.
This was the best advice
I ever got.
Live every day as if it's your
last, because one day you're
going to be right.
Because when you live every
day as if it's your last,
you're giving life some
kind of urgency.
You know, we're not all
going to live forever.
We're here temporarily.
What we have is a
temporary gift.
This thing we call life, it's
fun, but it's over.
And it's only temporary.
So when you look in the mirror,
and you say, today is
my last day, let me give you
an example how I do it.
I was in Turkey with my wife.
And we were in a resort
area called Bodrum.
It's not bedroom.
And she's talking about
going to Pamukkale.
Let's go to Pamukkale.
And I said, what's Pamukkale?
She said, I read all about it.
It's a beautiful place.
You must come.
It's 12 hours by Turkish
bus there and 12 hours
by Turkish bus back.
I said, sweetheart, you
go, I'm staying here.
She said, I am going.
But why aren't you coming?
And I said, because today's my
last day, and I don't feel
like dying on a bus.
So she said, where do you
want to die today?
Great question.
We should all be asking
ourselves that.
So she said, where do you
want to die today?
I said, next to the pool with
a nice cold glass of beer.
And if the angel of death
doesn't come, I'm going to
order a hamburger.
And this is a philosophy
I took from my mother.
My mother used to eat garlic,
garlic, every night before she
went to sleep.
One night, she forgot the
garlic, and here I am.
[LAUGHTER]
Let me explain it
to this side.
See, she ate--
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: --she
ate the garlic.
You see, my father came to bed,
and you know, one night
she forgot.
Never mind.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: I said,
Mom, why do you eat
garlic every night?
You know what she said?
She said, if the angel of death
comes tonight, I'll wake
up and ask, who is it?
The angel of death will go,
[SPITTING SOUND], I'll come
back tomorrow.
So we have now four tools, four
attitudes, I want you to
take with you.
Again, this is just awareness.
Any one you want to take
with you, laugh at
yourself and breathe.
Number two, stay hungry--
AUDIENCE: --stay foolish.
LEONARD RAVICH: Stay foolish.
Three, you've heard the
sentence, Mission Impossible?
Number three is mission
possible--
service--
serving happiness.
And number four is live every
day as if it's your last,
because one day you're
going to be right.
I think I have enough time.
Yes, number five.
But don't leave, I've
got a bonus for you.
Number five is this.
Remember, I told you who wants
to live a more flourishing
life, happier, healthier life?
OK, I want to give you a
sentence to say to everybody
who asks you this question.
And there's going to be a lot of
people who are going to ask
you this question.
And they're going to ask you,
how are you, hey, how you
doing, what's up, [GERMAN].
If you say this sentence to
everybody who says, how are
you, or asks you how you are,
the cells in your brain will
begin to change slowly
over time.
Trust me, this goes on.
If you say this sentence, the
cells in your body will begin
to change over time.
You'll start to think
differently and look different.
Your whole system will
reorganize itself to serve
you, to be happier serving
happiness.
Would you like to learn
that sentence or not?
AUDIENCE: [IN UNISON]
Yes.
LEONARD RAVICH: A little
bit more passion, OK.
AUDIENCE: [IN UNISON]
Yes.
LEONARD RAVICH: [SHOUTING]
Would you like to learn
that sentence or not?
AUDIENCE: [IN UNISON]
Yes!
LEONARD RAVICH: That's
passion.
If somebody comes over
to you and says, hi,
how are you, Alex?
The answer is this.
Now is my best moment, because
there is no other moment.
And it's gone.
Another one's gone.
So when is your best, most
exciting, most significant
moment in your life?
When?
AUDIENCE: [IN UNISON]
Now.
LEONARD RAVICH: I
can't hear you.
When?
AUDIENCE: [IN UNISON]
Now.
LEONARD RAVICH: All
you've got is now.
I say this to my neighbors.
I make sure that everybody knows
this when they ask me on
the bus or in the elevator.
They say, Lenny, how are you?
And I say, now is my best
moment, because there is no
other moment.
And they say to me, that means
something's wrong with you.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: Don't
you read the news?
My wife does not
watch the news.
She records the news.
Then, she watches it much later,
comes to me and says,
boy, am I glad that's over.
The past is history,
the future--
AUDIENCE: --a mystery.
LEONARD RAVICH: A mystery.
All we have is the--
AUDIENCE: --present.
LEONARD RAVICH: Present?
What is present?
AUDIENCE: Now.
AUDIENCE: A gift.
LEONARD RAVICH: A gift.
You give someone a present,
you give a gift.
If you're living in the
present, you're
living in the gift.
How many people--
if anybody here right
now feels the gift--
if you feel the gift
right now, applaud.
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD RAVICH: A
little louder.
Who feels the gift now?
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD RAVICH: I got enough
time for a bonus.
Did I hear somebody
say something?
Are you enjoying yourself
so far?
AUDIENCE: [IN UNISON]
Yes.
LEONARD RAVICH: Because
we're about to finish.
And you can't get me
again after this.
You know, you'll have
to call me.
Lenny, come back.
I want you to do me a favor
and start to dream.
And don't go around
with an editor in
your head or critic--
when you say, you know
what I would love?
I would love, nah, you
can't do that.
Or somebody says, you
can't do that--
OK, I want you to please
dream and make your
dreams become a reality.
And I'm not just saying that.
I'm going to do it for
you right now.
There's nothing here today, that
I said to you, that you
didn't get instruction exactly
from me how to do it.
Laughing at ourselves,
being foolish, OK?
I did it all, because
I want you to see it
and think about it.
And I want you to see right now
and witness somebody who
has a dream and makes that
dream become a reality.
Are you ready for this?
I have a dream right now.
And my dream is that I say
to you, how are you?
I envision, in my mind's eye,
that all of you yell back,
with great passion, now is my
best moment, because there is
no other moment.
And then I envision myself
saying to you, thank you,
Google, for inviting
me into your lives.
And thank you for coming
into mine.
And then, I envision all
of you standing up--
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: --and giving
me a standing ovation,
screaming, bravo, with
whistles and screams.
And then you sing to
me, that's the
way, uh, uh, uh, huh--
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: --I like
it, uh, huh, uh, huh.
Now, why is this dream important
for me to come true?
Because when I leave here, I'm
going to call my wife.
And I know exactly what
she's going to ask me.
Hi, how was it at Google?
And I'm going to say these
words to her, exactly,
Darling, you won't
believe this.
At the end of my talk,
everybody stood up.
They gave me a standing
ovation.
You won't believe this.
They screamed, bravo.
Yeah.
And you know what else?
They sang to me, that's the way,
uh, huh, I like it, uh,
huh, uh, huh.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: And I don't
want to lie to her.
So don't embarrass me.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: OK, let's make
his dream a reality.
How are you?
LEONARD RAVICH WITH AUDIENCE:
Now is my best moment, because
there is no other moment.
LEONARD RAVICH: And thank you,
Google, for inviting
me into your life.
And thank you for coming
into mine.
Get up!
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
LEONARD RAVICH WITH AUDIENCE:
That's the way, uh, huh, uh,
huh, I like it, uh,
huh, uh, huh.
That's the way, uh, huh,
uh, huh, I like it--
AUDIENCE: -uh, huh, uh, huh.
LEONARD RAVICH: Thank
you so much.
Thank you, thank
you, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD RAVICH: Right
on time, boom.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Questions?
May I have five minutes
for questions?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Any questions?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Does anyone have
any questions for Lenny?
I guess not.
LEONARD RAVICH: Yes?
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: Vicki.
LEONARD RAVICH: Vicki.
Yes, Vicki.
I have to stand here,
Vicki, because the
microphones is here.
AUDIENCE: What is the happiest
moment of your life so far?
LEONARD RAVICH: Right now.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: Ask me again.
AUDIENCE: What's the happiest
moment of your life so far?
LEONARD RAVICH: Right now.
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: Let's
keep doing this.
Really, I can't think of any
other moment but this.
And I can't think of a happier
moment than right now.
Thank you for the question.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you keep your
attitude like that every day?
LEONARD RAVICH: How do I keep
this attitude every day?
In the morning, I won't get
out of bed until I have
thanked God for everything
I have.
I go through a tremendous list
of perfect health, family,
friends, children,
grandchildren.
And I think, if you do that
every day, it's called an
attitude of gratitude, I just
simply won't get out of bed
until I thank God for allowing
me to take what she has given
me and has helped me to give to
you, to take my gifts, what
I do best, what God has given
me, so I'm able to relate it
to you, to bring today.
So I'm thankful for this.
I'm thankful for
the creativity.
I'm thankful for my life.
I'm thankful for everything.
And I go through a whole list.
And every night before I go to
sleep, I go through this whole
list again.
And this keeps my attitude up
and my feelings good, because
I have a lot to be
grateful for.
And it's called attitude
of gratitude.
And I think that you
all could do that.
It's better than counting sheep
before you go to sleep,
you know, [SNORE]
two, three, and so on.
Here comes a blessing.
You know, this.
And think, you'll find so many
wonderful things about your
life that you have that we
take for granted that you
could just give thanks
for, OK?
Does that answer
your question?
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just as a follow up,
in particularly difficult
time, if it happened in any
life, difficult times, how do
you practice this?
LEONARD RAVICH: How did I
deal in difficult times?
AUDIENCE: Very difficult
times.
LEONARD RAVICH: Very
difficult times.
I had a lot of faith.
I felt that somehow there was
a certain belief that I was
going to get through this.
And in many times in my life, I
think 100% of the time, when
I really look back
at the difficult
times, I caused them.
And the reason I caused
them was because I
had to learn a lesson.
If I look back on my life, and
I think of all the monsters
I've met along the way,
those monsters have
been my best teachers.
Those difficult moments have
made me into the human being
that I am today.
And so without the difficult
times, I wouldn't have been
able to be on this journey.
And if I look back on it
all, I created it.
Every monster I created.
And I learned, through a movie
I once saw called "Shrek,"
that everybody--
did you see "Shrek"--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LEONARD RAVICH: --where the
donkey and Shrek come to take
the princess and there's
a dragon?
And the dragon is scaring
everybody and breathing fire.
And the only one that faces
the dragon is the donkey.
And he looks into her eyes.
He says, oh, you're
a girl dragon.
And she goes [PREENING GESTURE].
[LAUGHTER]
LEONARD RAVICH: That's the way
I look at my dragons today.
I try to find something
beautiful, something exquisite
about them, and turn those
dragons into something lovely.
He finally marries her,
and they have
dragon-donkey children.
Thank you for coming.
Really enjoyed it, yes.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Guys,
there's also books.
If you want to enjoy
Lenny's humor more,
there's books for sale.
And otherwise, thanks
for bringing some
light into our afternoon.
LEONARD RAVICH: OK,
my pleasure.
MALE SPEAKER 1: It was
very enjoyable.
LEONARD RAVICH: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Thank
you very much.
LEONARD RAVICH: Thank you.